is
is there this do you worry about this is
there
any chance that one of these fellas
destroys all of human civilization by
um an asteroid kind of colliding with
something changing his trajectory and
then heading its way towards earth
that is definitely possible and it
doesn't even
have to necessarily collide and change
its trajectory
we're not tracking all of them we can't
track all of them yet
you know there's still
a lot of them people are people are
tracking a lot of them and we are doing
our best to track more of them but there
are a lot of them out there
and it would be potentially catastrophic
if one of them
impacted earth um have you are you aware
of this um
apophis object so there's an asteroid a
near-earth
object called apophis that people
thought had a
decent probability of hitting earth in
2029 and then potentially again in 2036
so they did a lot of studies it's not
actually going to hit earth
but it is going to come very close it's
going to be visible in the sky
in a relatively dark i mean not even
that dark
probably not visible from los angeles
but
um and it's going to come
a tenth of the way between the earth and
the moon it's going to come closer
apparently than some geosynchronous
communication satellites
oh wow so that is a close call but
people have studied it and then
apparently are very confident it's not
actually going to hit us but it was
gonna have to look into this because i
i'm very sure i'm very sure what's gonna
happen
if an asteroid actually hits earth
that the scientific community
and government will confidently say
that uh we have nothing to worry about
it's going to be a close call
and then last minute they'd be like
there was a miscalculation
they're not lying it's just like the
space of possibilities
because it's very difficult to track
these kinds of things and there's a lot
of kind of
there's complexities involved in this
there's a lot of uncertainties
that i just something tells me that
human civilization will end with we'll
see it coming
and then the last minute there will be
uh oops
well like we'll see it coming and we'll
be like no it's this is
this is threatening but no problem no
problem and last minute it would be like
oops that was a miscalculation
and then it's all over in a matter of
like a week
[Laughter]
or just very positive and optimistic
today is there
any chance that bruce willis can save us
in the sense that
from what you know about asteroids is
there something that um
you can catch them early enough to uh
change volcanic uh eruptions right
sort of drill put a nuclear weapon
inside and
break up the asteroid or change its
trajectory
there is potential for that if you catch
it early enough
in advance um i think
in theory if you knew
five years in advance ibm um
depending on the objects and how closely
how much you would need to deflect it
you could deflect it a little bit i
don't know
that it would be sufficient in all cases
and this is definitely not
my specific area of expertise but my
understanding is that
there is something you could do um but
it also
how you would carry that out depends a
lot on the properties of the asteroid if
it's a solid object versus a rubble pile
so let's say you planted some bomb
in the middle of it and it blew up but
it was just kind of a pile of material
anyway
and then that material comes back
together and then you kind of just have
the same thing
presumably its trajectory would be
altered but
it's it's like terminator 2 when it's
like the thing that's just like
you shoot it and splashes and then it
comes back together will be very useless
that's fascinating and what's
fascinating
i've gotten a lot of hope
from watching uh uh spacex rockets that
land
there's so much it's like oh wow from my
ai perspective from a robotics
perspective
that wow we can do a hell of an amazing
job
with control
and but then we have an understanding
about surfaces here on earth we can
map up a lot of things i wonder if we
can do that some kind of detail
of being able to have that same level of
precision
in landing on surfaces with as
wide of a variety as asteroids have so
be able to understand
the exact properties of the surface and
be able to encode that into whatever
rocket that lands
sufficiently to i presume humans unlike
them
unlike the movies humans would likely
get in the way
like it should all be done by robots and
like
land drill place the
the explosive that should all be done to
control
the robots and then you should be able
to dynamically adjust to um
to the surface the flip side of that for
a robotics person
i don't know if you've seen these it's
been very heartbreaking
uh somebody i know well russ tedrick at
mit
led the darpa robotics challenge team
for the humanoid robot challenge for
darpa i don't know if you've seen videos
of robots on two feet falling
but you're talking about millions you
know several years of work from
with some of the most brilliant
roboticists in the world millions of
dollars and the final thing is a
highlight
video on youtube of robots falling but
they had a lot of trouble
with uneven surfaces that's basically
what you have to do with uh
the challenge involves you're mostly
autonomous with some
partial human communication but that
human communication is broken up
like you don't get a you get a noisy
channel so you can
humans can which is very similar to what
it would be like
in humans remotely operating a thing on
an asteroid
and so with that robots really struggle
there's some hilarious
painful videos of like a robot not able
to like open the door
and then it tries to open the door
without like misses the handle and
in doing so like falls it's um
it's painful to watch so like that
there's that
and then there's spacex so i have hope
from spacex
and then i have less hope from bipeda
robotics um
but it's fun it's fun to kind of imagine
and i think the planetary
side of it comes into play in
understanding the surfaces of these
asteroids more and more
that you know forget sort of destruction
of human civilization
it'd be cool to have like spacecraft
just landing on all these asteroids to
study them
at scale and being able to figure out
dynamically
what you know whether it's a rubble pile
or whether it's um
a solid objects do you see that kind of
future of science
maybe 100 200 300 years from now where
there's just
robots expanding out through the solar
system
like sensors essentially some of it
taking pictures from a distance some of
them landing just exploring and giving
us data
because it feels like we're working with
very little data right now
sure i i do see exploration going that
way i think
[Music]
the way that nasa is currently
or historically has been doing missions
is putting together these these really
large
missions that do a lot of things that
are extremely well tested and have a
very low rate of failure but
now that um these sort of cubesat
technologies are are becoming easier to
build
easier to launch they're they're very
cheap and you know nasa is getting
involved in this as well there's there's
a lot of interest in these missions that
are
relatively small relatively cheap and
just do one thing so you can really
optimize it to
just do this one thing and maybe you
could build 100 of them and send them to
different asteroids and they would just
collect this one piece of information
from each asteroid
it's a kind of different more
distributed way of doing science i guess
and there's a ton of potential there i
agree
you